[Music]
the National Football League recently
had their annual offseason League
meeting and something pretty interesting
happened NFL officials announced several
rule changes for the 2016 season some of
the rules the new ones are pretty
interesting I thought we'd take a look
at them right now if you're interested
let's take a look first we will check
this out it says all chopped blocks are
illegal and then this one says extra
point line will be permanently moved to
15-yard line
those are fine but then they get a
little strange check this one out
fumbles will now be called oopsies check
this one out if a player scores a
touchdown he must kneel and give thanks
to Papa John but of this players can
only be arrested in the months of March
April May June July and August
that's a good idea after a player is
penalized the referee will also reveal
his darkest secret for example holding
on number 78 a man who is sexually
attracted to clowns that would be me
and finally quarterbacks will start at
the line of scrimmage blindfolded then
we'll move from linemen to linemen until
the butt feels like the right one
[Music]
that's my move
you